[Music]
calculator
Israel is doing a lot of people have
been calling Collective punishments the
collective punishment under the pretext
of them searching for this one suspect
so there's been thousands to tens of
thousands of people stuck at hours at
checkpoints elderly people children
patients not being able to get where
they want to
[Music]
the ground over the past few months and
attentions have been increasing there is
growing orange resistance while seeing
an armed resistance in cities like
cannabis engineering and the northern
occupied West Bank
so the the numbers of shootings at
military checkpoints and that soldiers
have increased in the last period
[Music]
they have been carrying out consecutive
attacks on people and whether in
Annapolis or the surrounding areas
um dozens of Palestinians have been
injured
um their properties destructed whether
it was their homes their stores their
cars sectors have been using live
ammunition in front of Israeli soldiers
they've been using pipes uh large rocks
physically beating residents
week-long program
of protests marches
um
rallies and confrontations with Israeli
forces enable us to protest the siege
there has been growing solidarity with
the armed resistance groups even though
they are small and have limited
capabilities
um Palestinians feel that they need
someone to to defend them
[Music]